[Applause]
H they can't help
themselves Biden spins racist fables as
V turns the tables Joe Biden released
his first 2024 reelection ad frankly
it's just nice to see him releasing
something besides
gas but instead of launching a campaign
he celebrates Insurrection Christmas a
holiday more imaginary than
Quanza roll it Diego quickly I've made
the preservation of American democracy
the central issue of my presidency I
believe in free and fair elections and
the right to vote fairly and have your
vote
counted there's something dangerous
happened in America there's an extremist
movement who does not share the basic
beliefs in our democracy all of us are
being asked right now what will we do to
maintain our democracy I didn't know
Jesse Smet was a
director so you get that America you're
the dangerous Insidious extremist
problem that's threatening
democracy but hey if I had Biden's
record I'd blame white people too
starting with him it's almost three
years to the day since chance 6 and
Biden's still flapping his toothless
gums about it probably since it's also
the date of his last solid bowel
movement and notice the imagery torch
wielding young whites marching into the
night Confederate flag caring old white
men marching during the day that 30
seconds is about all the footage they
have like that it's an amazing sentence
according to Old Joe everyone who
doesn't support him is a racist magga
nut which if you've seen Joe's poll
numbers lately is roughly 99.9% of the
country so what's the response to this
white supremacy hysteria Behold a master
class from V
ramaswami do you condemn white supremacy
and white nationalism I mean what this
kind who are you with it's Washington
Post s right so potato potato
okay of course I condemn any form of
vicious racial discrimination in this
country but I think that the presumption
of your
question is fundamentally based on a
falsehood that that really is the main
form of racial discrimination we see in
this country today stop picking on this
farce of some figment that exists at
some infinitesimally small Fringe of the
American public today to open our eyes
to the actual real threats that we face
and I think that it's frankly questions
and framings like that that has caused
the American public to lose all trust in
the mainstream media I'm sorry to say
for good
reason that's pretty good I don't think
he's sorry to say it though I think all
those appearances on my show really must
have paid
off take us home VI you didn't say that
you condemn white supremacy though I'm
not I'm not going to recite some
catechism for you I'm against vicious
racial discrimination in this country so
I'm not pledging allegiance to your new
religion of modern w B ISM which
absolutely Feats fits the test I'm not
going to bend the need of your religion
I'm sorry I'm not asking you to bend the
need of mine and I'm not going to bend
the need of yours but do I condemn
vicious racial discrimination yes I do
am I going to play your silly game of
gotcha no I'm not and I know you're
going to go print the headline tomorrow
I already know this we already know how
your game works vas Swami refuses to
condemn white supremacy because you
asked a stupid question shame on you
look people in the eye and tell them
what you've actually failed to tell them
for the Last 5 Years own the
accountability for your own failures as
the media that's how we rebuild trust in
this country and until then I don't have
a lot of patience to play the games
nice yeah if there's
any meritocracy left in this world the
reporter should already be filling out
an application as a Walmart greeter this
guy he predicted exactly what she would
do I don't know if you saw the
reporter's tweet she did exactly what he
said she goes he refused to condemn
white supremacy even though he did but
he goes but you're going to say the
opposite it's pretty amazing when you're
that stupid to have the guy predict your
move out loud to your face and then you
rush off to do it to prove him correct
look if we lived iner times the reporter
asked a question hi Mr ramaswami yeah do
you condemn white supremacy and all he
would have to do is
say that's it look at me like he's a
secret closet white supremacist Viv
ramas Swami is the secret white
supremacist it's crazy but this is what
we're up against these days where Larry
Elder was called a white supremacist
Asian people are called white supremacy
adjacent it's just broken brain nonsense
so it's nice to see someone basically
take a 2x4 rhetorically and hit the
media over the head with it and make
their head spin so badly that they go
and fulfill his own prediction the next
day that's pretty impressive it was nuts
it is obvious eron that the bidens have
no policy so they have to go after the
people
and that includes Trump obviously but
anybody who supports him like they they
they have nothing to C they're not even
campaigning oh that's right and to to
roll out your campaign in an ad that is
just so emotionally charged shows you
the vulnerability of this campaign super
fast this guy has been president for
three years now and his first message to
the American people is you need to be
terrified for your life not that I've
done a good job not that the econom is
better not that our streets are safer
not that he has a message of success to
run on he's just running on fear and
polling shows exactly why he's doing
that people who are right now likely
Trump voters are looking at when they're
asked 1 to 10 How likely are you like
what's your level of enthusiasm like 45%
nearly says 10 these people will run
through a brick wall to go vote for
Biden that number sits at like 15% so he
needs to try to drum up a motion to get
people to buy into his nonsense because
he doesn't have the policy he doesn't
have the success so he's just going to
try to pull it whatever strand he thinks
he can to get people to like have little
fire in their gut form and I have to say
that's not a good ad by any stretch of
the imagination by campaign standards
they should have taken time to have him
read a script he is like slurring words
throughout he says United States
America United States of America it
wasn't even live I mean you can redo it
you could the best one that was
take7 look how you are when they mess up
the teleprompter can you imagine old
Corn Pop
telling them hey uh it's pronounced
United States of America
not and if you say it properly next time
Mr President you get ice
cream I
just he also says he made the
preservation of American democracy you
know an essential issue of my presidency
as if we're supposed to be impressed by
that cuz to me that's like the lowest
bar exactly don't you say that like when
you put your hand on the Bible
for me our government is still
functioning I'm not though and do you
see sometimes that should that is the
bar in DC like B we're still functioning
look at us well done but he's actually
like it's barely functioning he's broken
a lot of things yeah he's he's well I
wouldn't say he's a bull in a china shop
but he's like an old man falling around
a china shop yeah what blows go if you
if we run those commercials back mhm
pretty much I'm I'm not a betting man
but I'm willing to bet everyone in those
videos was arrested yeah there's like
less than six left out on the street
from January 6th you know what I'm
saying like who is left that's at large
from January 6 besides like the the FBI
plants and stuff who was left like we we
watched the movie we watched the
production of January 6 so whom is left
from that group and isn't looking at 20
to 30 yeah you know so the the the they
arrested everybody so where's the threat
yeah exactly cuz they're all in jail
even if someone says hey my birthday's
on January 6th there's a good chance
your ass is going to jail my dog's
birthday is on January 6 don't say that
out loud cuz car birthday is on January
6th and it's another year we can't
celebrate it there's also this this
dichotomy where in the ad they're like
democracy voting rights our system and
then the other headlines in the real
world are we're trying to get our main
opponent thrown off the ballot that's a
little bit odd there's some dissonance
there it is it is cat who who's your
secret Santa for January 6th oh god well
it was like the first January 6 the
first anniversary was obviously the
worst day in my life and then but also
we couldn't celebrate Carl's birthday
it's not his fault he was born on
January 6 it's no one's fault yeah all
right we got to move on hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else